the new year is the perfect time for all
of us to reset our bodies and reset our
minds it really is and for Ashton
Kutcher that meant an emotional
conversation about his twin brother
Michael who has cerebral palsy Ashton
revealing how watching his brother
suffer caused him to consider the
unthinkable
I'm like how do I get to be
this lucky and for my brother to have
like
be born with Cerebral Palsy then have a
heart's transplant then have this random
blood clot when his brother got sick at
a young age and started to say hey I
needed a heart transplant I actually
went to his parents and said you know
take my heart and he said it truthfully
he really wanted to give it to his
brother he looked at me and he said
every time you feel sorry for me you
make me less
and he said this is the only life I've
ever known
so stop feeling sorry for the only thing
I have
Ashton's startling confession he
considered jumping off a balcony to end
his life and save Michaels when the two
were just 13 years old decades later the
memory of watching his brother Flatline
while waiting for a donor is still
emotional and they're like
they're grabbing me and they take me out
and I'm like what the hell is going like
so it
foreign
the 44 year old father of two also
shares intimate details of his own
near-death experience in the checkup
with Dr David agus streaming now on
Paramount plus I woke up one day and
like was having Vision issues could
hardly see and I couldn't walk it came
to a point where Mila called me and said
Ashton is just you know he's not saying
things that make sense
and he actually ended up losing his
eyesight his hearing and the blood
vessels in his brain had an autoimmune
reaction called a vasculitis it looked
like my appendix was being choked by
endometriosis and they found a tumor in
there Amy Schumer uses humor to open up
about her numerous Health struggles
including pregnancy complications a
hysterectomy and an appendectomy last
year after a c-section like nothing
really feels to me like that big of a
deal Amy also reveals a battle with
trichotillomania a form of OCD where
patients pull out their own hair it's
still humiliating and shameful I still
struggle with it
you're still doing it luckily I have
hair extensions and it's the only reason
I can be on camera other stars not
holding back Jane Fonda who recently
announced her remission from cancer and
talks about her recovery from a past
eating disorder if I had anything too
over and it was nowadays right I'd
probably go to a 12-step program or
something Nick Cannon explained the
despair felt when he lost his
five-month-old son Zen to a rare form of
brain cancer just over a year ago that
last weekend I kind of knew like this is
probably going to be the last weekend
luckily we had did everything from
the sunrise and going to the beach and
you know the sunset I'm grateful for
that in October Zen's mom Alyssa Scott
announced they're expecting another
child together Nick has also been
dealing with his own health struggles
last month Nick was hospitalized with
the pneumonia he also battles the
autoimmune disease lupus which nearly
took his life he went into kidney
failure and had a blood clot in his lung
and several times came close to dying
from them once he learned he's
preventing them and he's in remarkable
shape now Oprah is hoping to inform
others about the sometimes terrifying
symptoms of menopause I was like
severely palpitating
and every night I have journals filled
with I don't know if I'll make it till
the morning I thought I was going to die
every single night this is a natural
transition so she's heroic to be so
vulnerable with what she went through
[Music]